[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
ايران تسعى لتثبيت نفوذها السياسي في
العراق عبر الجغرافيا الاقتصاديه والسؤال
اين واشنطن
روسيا تدفعوا واشنطن الى محاضره اوكرانيه
لكنها تقع في فخذ والنتيجه مفتاح الجنوب
قد يضيع وفي ملفاته
نحو ولايه اخيره او سقوتا اول اردوغان
يلعبوا اوراقه الانتخابيه من الليره
وسوريا وصولا الى اليونان
الملياردير المغامر يراكم وخسائره واعدائه
ايضا او وجبه جديده صندوق تويتر الاسود
[موسيقى]
في العراق ازمات كثيره وحلول قليله او
ربما معدومه وتشكيل الحكومه الجديده
برئاسه محمد الشياع السوداني لم يحل
الكثير من الامور الخلافات باتت الان بين
كتل الاطار التنسيقيه الموالي لايران
والمناصب لا تزالوا شاغره ومنها رئاسه
جهاز الاستخبارات منصب مهم لايران بالطبع
والخلافه هنا بين ميليشيا العصائب وحركه
حقوق الجناح السياسي للشيخ حزب الله تنفيذ
بنود الاتفاق السياسي خلاف اخر وهذه المره
تحاول اطراف داخل قوى الاطار عرقله البنود
الخاصه بمطالب القوى السنيه وخصوصا تلك
المتعلقه بالسحب الفصائل من المناطق التي
كانت تحت سيطره داعش اتفاقيه سنجار
المواقع بين بغداد واربيل حبر على ورق حتى
الان خلاف ثالث ودوره ايران هناك طبعا لا
يغيب الطيران تتدخل في شؤون الجيرانها
وتطلب وعدم تدخلي في شئونها الاحتجاجات
تعم الشوارع ايران الفصائل المسلحه
التابعه لها لن تتخلى بسهوله عن سنجر
باعتبار المدينه وسيله الضغط على واشنطن
وبغداد
كردستان
السلطات الايرانيه لا تريد ان تتاثر
سياستها التوسعيه في العراق وفي هذه
الاوضاع خصوصا وانها لديها جبهه داخليه
الاحتجاجات ومن هنا جاءت زياره السوداني
لطيران خلال العقدين الاخيرين اعتاد
الطيران على دعوتي رؤساء الحكومات
لزيارتها بعد منحها الثقه من قبل البرلمان
لكن توقيت تلبيه الدعوه يخضع لعده اعتبارا
السياسيه وزياره السوداني جاءت سريعه
وتحديدا بعد اسبوع من زياره قائد الفيلق
القدس في الحرس الثوري العراق والذي قاد
تحالفات تشكيل حكومه السوداني وبعد
التوترات على الحدود مع كردستان العراق
احراج داخلي وخارجي للحكومه العراقيه لكن
الاعتبارات السياسيه ليست بعيده عن
الاقتصاد طبعا تعتبروا الطيران الجغرافيا
الاقتصاديه العراقيه مكمله لتثبيتين بها
السياسيه تريد زياده منافذ التصدير ليصل
التبادل التجاري الى 20 مليار دولار
اقتصاد طيران متدهور وتريد الحلول والعراق
غنيم طبعا لكنه منوب لكن اللافت في
الاتفاقات المواقع ها هو تاسيس مكتب
تمثيلي لوزاره النفط الايرانيه في العراق
والعهده على وكاله مهر الايرانيه خطوه
سياسيه بامتياز تتجاوز الرغبه بتطوير
التعاون في النفط والغاز النحو السيطره
على القطاع والتعاقدتين لما لا وعائله
العراق من النفط الخام فقط خلال العام
الجاري بلغتنا احوال 100 مليار دولار
سيطره وهيمنه واستفاده اقتصاديه نعم لكنها
ايضا ورقه ضغطا سياسيه ثانيه بجانب التي
تحدثنا عنها قبل قليل وهذه المره على
الدول الاوروبيه المتؤثره بنقص الطاقه
نتيجه الحرب الاوكرانيه وايضا
على الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
حين تعهد رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شيعه
السوداني في طهران بالضبط امن الحدود شكك
المرشد الايراني بذلك ويبدو ان هذا الملف
ليس الوحيد الذي يشكك فيه
اعترف خلال لقائه بالسوداني في ظهران لفشل
مذكرات التفاهم والتعاون بين البلدين
وانها لم تصل الى مرحله العمل والعهده هنا
على ايران انترناشونال
يريد اذا اتحركا عمليا في مجال التعاون
الاقتصادي والتبادل البضائع والسكك
الحديديه يدفع المرشد الى هذا الاتجاه
ولابد من المزيد لكن لماذا الاجابه في
مباحثات اعاده احياء الاتفاق النووي
الايرانيه المؤشرات ليست في صالح طهران
لكن الى اي مدى تتغلغل ايران في الاقتصاد
العراقي لدي ازرع اقتصاديه استراتيجيه او
وجدت بيئه خارجيه تتحرك فيها طهران بحريه
وهي المؤسسات الايرانيه في العراق
اعاده الاعمار بوابه الشركات الايرانيه
للهيمنه الاستثماريه والخدميه ايضا مهمه
الحشد يعد السعاده المناطق من داعش هي منح
عمليات اعاده الاعمار في تلك المدن اللي
الشركات الايرانيه فهل هناك منافسه لا
وتحسمها قوه السلاح
شركاتنا في جميع المجالات ثم مثلا في مجال
المقاولات لو ارادت شركه عراقيه او اجنبيه
المنافسات ستصطدم لشبكه ايرانيه منها شركه
الكوثر التي اسسها فيلق القدس في 2003 وفي
مجال الطاقه الاصطدام سيكون بشركات
ايرانيه ومنها شركه مبنى التابعه وزاره
الطاقه الايرانيه
على كل حال الحديث عن الهيمنه الايرانيه
طويل ويطول اكثر والمتضرر الاول هو
المواطن العراقي الذي باتم رغما على
التعاطي مع المنتجات والخدمات الايرانيه
حسره طيران اتعملوا على ضرب الاقتصاد
العراقي وتحويله الى اقتصاد المستهلك
واغلاق السوق العراقي
بصناعاتها ومنتجاتها مثلا البضائع التي
تمر عبر الحدود من ايران الى العراق لا
تخضع للفحص او المواصفات والمقاييس شهاده
المنشا قد تكون كافيه لعمرها اما في مجال
الطاقه تمكنت ايران من رفع صادراتها
النفطيه الى العراق مثلا بدايه العام 2018
من 30% الى 50% بعد عمليه التدمير ومن
منهج للمصافي النفسيه في مدينه صلاح الدين
العراقيه اثناء تحريرها تنظيم داعش وفي
ازمه الكهرباء ايران تزود العراق بثلث
حاجاته من الغاز والكهرباء وبالمناسبه
يحرق العراق اكثر من مليار ونصف لمليار
قدم مكعب من الغاز المصاحب للنفط يوميا اي
10 اضعاف الكميه المستورده من ايران بقيمه
تقدر بنحو مليرين ونصف المليار دولار
سنويا ودهون الاستفاده منه
ايضا في قطاع الفندق حتى بات المستثمرون
الايرانيون المهيمنون على المشاريع الكبرى
في مدينتي كربلاء والنجف اضافه الى
السيطره الايرانيه على قطاع النقل البري
والجوي
ترسخوا ايران نفسها عبر مؤسساتها وعبر
اذرعها ايضا وليس سياسيا وامنيا فحسب انما
اقتصاديا على الوجه الاخر للنفوذ
الايرانيه المتمدده في العراق وعنوانه
ميليشيا الحشد الشعبي
اترى قرار الحكومه العراقيه بالموافقه على
انشاء شركه عامه براس مالا يقارب السبعين
مليون دولار الكثير من القلق في البلاد
لماذا
الارتباط هذه الشركه بالحشد الشعبي والتي
سميت بشركه المهندس بالنسبه لابي المهدي
المهندس بقى رئيس الحشد الذي اختلته
واشنطن مع قاسم سليمان قائد فيلق القدس في
يناير 2020 لكن اين يكمن القلق مهمه
الشركات تتمثلوا في اعاده تاهيل البنيه
التحتيه في المحافظات وهو ما قاضي يعني ان
الحشد تحول الى مؤسسه ربحيه بيدران
ليس هذا فحسبه الخطوه وصفت بحشدنه
الاقتصاد العراقي وتوغل المليشيا في
صناعات الدوله ومواردها وهو ماذا يعني ان
ثنائيه المال والسلاح ستقتل اي منافسه على
فرص الاستثمار الامر اشبه باستنساخ تجربه
الحرس الثوري والبسيج اجنحه النظام
الايراني المهيمن على الاقتصاد في ايران
الذي انه اصلا والاقتصاد العراقي الذي
يعاني بلاساس ستزيد معاناته يبقى سؤاله
هنا هنا اين الولايات المتحده من كل هذا
في الخفاء تعرف واشنطن ان الاطراف التي
شكلت الحكومه معروفه بعدائها لها بحكم
ولائها لايران لكن في العالم تؤكد امريكا
دائما انها لن تترك العراق زي العراق
قامت بها السفيره الامريكيه في بغداد
لرئيس الوزراء محمد شياع السوداني امر
يحدث للمراه الاولى مع رئيس الحكومه لكن
هذا كافل لمواجهه الهيمنه الايرانيه عمليا
لا واشنطن لديها اولويات حرب اوكرانيا
وروسيا ومواجهه نفوذ الصين
تحاول ايران الالتفاف على العقوبات
الامريكيه والاوروبيه الاقتصاديه المفروضه
عليها من خلال السوق العراقي والتي تسعى
للسيطره على اغلب المفاصلها والتي تعتبر
الاقرب لها جغرافيا وحتى سياسيه
الحديقه الخلفيه او الرئه الاقتصاديه
لايران هكذا ترى طهران والعراق والسبب
الميزان التجاري الذي يبلغوا نحو عشره
مليارات دولار سنويا من خلاله اغلاق السوق
العراقيه بالبضائع والسلع الايرانيه حيث
يعتبر العراق النافذه الاكبر في المنطقه
الصادرات الايرانيه تسيطر ايران بشكل شبه
كامل على سوق الطاقه في العراق من خلال
تجهيز نحو نصف ما يحتاجه العراق من
الكهرباء والغاز لسد احتياجاته لمنظمته
الكهربائيه اضافه لعمل الشركات النفطيه
الايرانيه في جنوبيه العراق قطاع المصاري
وشركات الصرافه هي الاخرى لم تستلم من
اذرع طيران التي تعمل على توفير الدولار
لايران والذي وصل الى ارقام قياسيه مقابل
التوما الايراني
العمله ومؤسسه الماليه العراقيه بحسب مصر
لمتابعتي هذا الملفاء ينضم الينا من عمان
الدكتور باسل حسين رئيس مركز كلودا
للدراسات والابحاث اهلا بك كانت امانه
العراقين في هذه الحكومه تقويه القطع
الخاص وخلق اقتصاد مزدوج لوقف هذه الهيمنه
الايرانيه والميليشاويه على الاقتصاد يعني
خطوه كهذه حشدانه الاقتصاد خلق مؤسسه
وتاسيس مؤسسات تتعلق بالبنيه التحتيه
للعراق في المحافظات بيد الحشد الشعبي في
اي مسار تسير حكومه السودان
مساء الخير سيدتي والمشاهده تكون الكرام
بالتاكيد هذا القرار فيه اشكاليات عند بدء
بالاشكاليه للقانونيه وايضا اشكاليات
الاخرى الامنيه والاقتصاديه اولا نبدا
بالاشكاليه القانونيه هذا القرار تاخذ حسب
ما يعلن البيان التاسيس على قانون الشركات
الماده الثامنه همم وهذا غير صحيح لان هذه
الماده تتحدث عن صلاحيه الوزارات بتشكيل
شركه همم الهيئه الحشد ليست وزاره
المستقله هي ليست الموارد في الدستور والى
اخره وكل واحد له خصوصيه وهم معروفه
وبالتالي عمليه تشكيل مخالف اللقاء
للقانون يعني للسناب غير صحيح وبالتالي
الدنيا امام اشكاليه
اشكاليه الاخرى هو الخشيه هناك خشيه
عراقيه حقيقيه من تكون هنالك
محاوله انشاء قوه موازيه
بثنائيه السلاح والمال
العائله السياسه ومن ثم الى الاقتصاد يعني
هذه الهيمنه الايرانيه ستكون مضاعفه
بالتاليه الى جانب كل
الهيمنه ايران على موارد العراق اضافه الى
هذه العناصر وهذه
المليشيات التي تمكينها اكثر من مسك
الاقتصاد العراقي الان
الايرانيون يعني لديهم نهم مستمره وجشع
مستمر تجاه العراق يريدون العلاقه ان يكون
الجزيره مغلق لهم على الرغم من بلوغ يعني
بدات التجاريه لصالح ايران ومقدار 10
مليار الا انهم ليسوا في رضا مستمر يريد
ان يصل الى 20 مليار غالب المكان
الاقتصادي العراقي يعمل في خدمه الاقتصاد
الايراني بل كان منفذ للهروب من العقوبات
الاقتصاديه طوال السنوات الماضيه على وكان
هناك من ارقام الوزاره
كانت واضحه في بعض السنوات بلغ فقط
استيراد الطماطم او البندوره مليار بوينت
6 وهذا رقم يو العراقي يسبحون بالبندوره
ايضا هذا الرقم
ومن بينها في زياره السودان الى ايران
تشمل تاسيس مكتب تمثيلي لوزاره
فقال الايرانيه ما فائده العراق من هذا
المكتب
هذا مر يعني همم غريب جدا هذا يعكس تماما
حجم الهيمن الايرانيه حينما يتم انشاء مثل
هذا المكتب حقيقه ما نفع هذا المكتب سوى
المحاوله انه
توظيف موارد العراق لصالح هي من الايراني
والا هذا يعني امر حقيقه مضحك جدا ان يكون
هناك مكتب تنفيذ في داخل همم الوزاره يعني
خرق يعني مفهوم سياد الوطنيه انه هذه
الوزاره السياديه لكنه لا يهتمون والحكومه
واضحه جدا هي تقول انها حكومه ايطاليا
ونعرف مدى هذه العلاقه العضويه ما بين همم
الاطار وما بين الحكومه الايرانيه
وبالتالي همم تراها الان فرصه ثانيه او
فرصه مناسبه لزياده حجم النفود الايراني
من عمان دكتور باسل حسين رئيس مركز كل
وادي للدراساتي والابحاث
المخزون مستنزفه والحرب مستعره وموسم
الاعياد لن يوقفها في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
ثلاث روسيا منذ الصيف التغلب على نكساتها
الثلاثه في الشمال الشرقي لمن في الشرق
واخرسون في الجنوب التوجه نحو احدى اقدم
مدن اوكرانيا مخموت الواقعه في الشرق
القروص بكل ثقلهم هناك جبهه محصنه يبلغ
طولها نحو 15 كيلو مترا استعانوا بباكنر
وسحبوا قواتنا من جبهه اخرى لهان الروسي
لكن هل هو كذلك ام مغامره غير محسوبه يبدو
ان موسكو او قاعه نفسها في الفخ التقدم
بطيء الخسائر كبيره روسيا تمضي رغم ذلك
بينما الخسائر الاكبر تاتي في جبهات اخرى
وليست فقط عسكريه بل حتى نفسيا الهجمات
وصلت للعنق الروسيه اوكرانيا استهدفت
قاعدتين جويتين انجلز التي تقع في منطقه
سيرته في يجلب وهو في ريازان عند تحديدا
لديها اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره وهي واحده
من قاعدتين استراتيجيتين للقاذفات توجد
فيهما القدرات النوويه الروسيه المحموله
جوا
برعت اوكرانيا التكتكيه كما وصفتها
الجارديان استمرت الي استهدفت لتستهدف
مطارات روسيه عبر المسيارات في مقاطعه
كورسكل الروسيه المحاديه لاوكرانيا لكن
هناك ما هو اخطر على روسيا قد يكون مدينه
من بيوتيفول او ما يعرفوا بمفتاح الجنوب
اوكرانيا استغلت هاجس روسيا ببخوت وضربت
من اليوتيوب والمستعينه بدعم واشنطن الى
شمته صواريخ الامر ذاته حصل في خرسون التي
استعادتها كيابه التهديد لموسكو يتزايد
اذا القوات الاوكرانيه تعمل الان على ضفه
الشرقيه لنهر النيفر مقابل خرسون وما قدرت
قواتها الان على وضعي انظمه صواريخ هان
وينكس على الضفه الغربيه يعني انها قادره
على اسقاط ميوتي بول وماذا يعني سقوط
المدينه انهيار خط الدفاع الروسي على طول
الطريق الى خرسون والكارثه على موسكو قد
تكون اكبر القوات الاوكرانيه قد تكتسبوا
طريقا مباشره الى شبه الجزيره
البعض والتي اصبحت ساحه لمعركه داميا بين
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه لكن خبراء
عسكريين تحدثوا عن عدم قدره القوات
الروسيه تحقيقا نجاحات هجوميه كبيره حتى
ذوبان الكامل للجليد بسبب صعوبه تقدمها
الان هذا القتال العنيف على هذه المنطقه
يعود لاسباب سياسيه ومعنويا بالنسبه
لروسيا وبالاخص بعد الانسحابات المتتاليه
للقوات الروسيه كان اخرها من خيرسون
مؤسسه مجموعه العسكريه والتي تدعم القوات
الروسيه فيها معركه اكد على ان موعد
الاستيلاء على هذه المنطقه ليس بالقريب
لان بخ مت هي منطقه كبيره محسنه يوجد فيها
ض هو حواجز مائيه ولان الجيش الاوكراني
على استعداد جيد ويقاوم بشده
الشتاء في اوكرانيا لم يجمدوا كل المعارك
لا توجد هناك هدنا محتمله في موسم الاعياد
موسكو وكيف تمتلكان العنصر البشري لكن
الامر مختلف بخصوص الاسلحه
الانتصار في بخمود سيكون اشاره قويه يرغب
زنسكي من خلالها باقناع الغرب بقدرته على
قلب المعارك ولتحقيق الاهداف على الغرب
ارسال المزيد من الاسلحه
اوكرانيا ترغب في صواريخ بعيده المدى
وانظمه دفاعا فعاله لكن استخدمنا روسيا
لورقه الضرب محطات الطاقه يبدو انه اقنع
واشنطن اخيرا لتقديمي بطاريات باتريات
ومتقدم في دفاعات حلف الناتو قبل
التواشنطن المخاطره فدخول باتريه ارض
المعارك قد يجعلها تقع بيد الروس الذين
اعلن انها ستكون هدفا مشروعا ان وصلت امرا
قد يتسبب في استنساخ التكنولوجيا او حتى
فقدانها لفاعليهتها
المخاطره الاخرى قبلتها واشنطن صاروخان من
باتريوت كلفتهما عاليه ثمانيه ملايين
دولار يمكن استخدامها في اعتراض هدفا واحد
مسيرات قيمتها 50,000$ وبالعوده الى بخموت
هنا مخاطره اخرى الطرفان يتبادلني الاف
القذف في المدفعيه يوميا انظمتها او ايرس
الالمانيه لا تتعامل بفعاليه مع القذائف
غير الموجهه ولذلك وجودها على الجبهه
سيجعله واقعها مكشوفه وبالتالي يسهل
تدميرها بطاريه واحده لن تغير مسار الحرب
وواحده لا تكفي ايضا لحمايتك والمدن
الكبرى وهذا بعد عن تكلفتها نصف مليار
دولار هناك مشكله اخرى ايضا تشغيل نظام
واحد يحتاج الى طاقم يتكون من 90 عسكريا
فكنا واشنطن لديها خطه للتدريب
[موسيقى]
في الجهه المقابله قد تطرى روسيا للتعامل
مع باتري طبي صواريخ متطوره فرق صوتيه
خاصه موسكو لم تتردد باعلان دخول صواريخ
يارس الخدمه وبمجرد موافقه واشنطن على
تقديم باثريه
تحمل رؤوسا نوويه لكن انخفاضها مخزون
الصواريخ الدقيقه قد يحكم على روسيا
استخدامها الاستهداف باتريات او ايرس بعد
راسها النووي اوكرانيا لما يتبقى لديها
مخزون اسلحه صوفيا ولا قدره على التصنيع
هنا يظهر الدعم الغربي وهنا لا يستنز في
الغرب ايضا حصوله اوكرانيا على انظمه
الباثريه المكلفه سي يرفع ميزانيه واشنطن
الموجه لاوكرانيا بسرعه وتدميرها كارثه
اخرى
الحرب تشهد مرحله انتقاليه الاستنزاف على
راس التحديات ان افترضنا ان واشنطن
ستواصلوا دعمها العسكري الذي بلغ 20 مليار
دولار حتى في ظل اعتراض الجمهوريين هناك
عقبه اخرى وهي الانتاج معارك وبخمود
تستهلك دخيره اكثر من انتاج الدول مجتمعه
امريكات تنتج 20 الف قذيفه مدفعيه الشهريا
بينما تستهلك اوكرانيا 80,000 العجز يعوضه
من المخزون الاستراتيجي الذي وصل الى
مستويات نفاد الحمراء بعيد عن حرب
المدفعيه في بخموت استراتيجيه مختلفه في
اليوتيوب فول صواريخ هاي مارس كلمه السر
في تكرار سيناري
طلبوا يؤرقوا واشنطن ارسلت كلوثها
لكل التعويض يحتاج تحتاجه الى ما يوازي
انتاج ست سنوات
الحرب تدور راحه ايضا في اوروبا المانيا
لم يعد لديها ما تعطيه وتقريرا لوزاره
الدفاع اكد حرفيا ان الجيش الالماني يفتقر
الى كل شيء من الملابس الى المعدات ووحده
احتياجاته من الذخيره تبلغ 20 مليار دولار
اما في روسيا فذخيره ليست مشكله هي عكس
الصواريخ الدقيقه لا تحتاج قطعا الكترونيا
مستورده صناعتها في روسيا لن تتاثر تحدي
موسكو يكمن في توفير الاموال الشرائح
الالكترونيه
للمزيد ينضم الينا من موسكو عبر سكايب
السرجال شاشكو بالمحلل العسكريه الروسيه
ابدا معك اولا من بخمول لماذا هذا الهوس
الروسي ببخموت والسيطره عليها
تسمى في روسيا عباره عن عقده المقاومه
القويه
المتبقيه في جمهوريه
فعندما اشار الرئيس مؤخرا الى مهامره
ماريه الواقع حاليا 10
خصوصا بضروره التحرير كل اراضي جمهوريه
الدنيا اذا الهدف الاول والرئيسي والاساسي
في المحلات التي همم
القضاء على القوات المتبقيه ومالك وهمم
محمود تجهيز لتطوير الهجوم همم
نعم سيد سيد لكن في الاثناء واثناء هذا
التركيز الشديد على هذه المدينه على بخموط
تلقت روسيا في العمق ضربات كثيره هل لهذا
طلب بوتن همم القاده العسكريين بتغيير
الاستراتيجيه في الحرب الاوكرانيه
في العنق الروسي همم هي كان رد على توجيه
الضربه الصاروخيه المكثفه على على المنشات
همم
الاقتصاديه الاوكرانيه ولاسيه همم
المحولات لمحاضرات الطاقه يعني المعلومه
في في رجل الاخير
ضربه قرانيه
فطبعا ااا بعد
ما تعرضت هذه القاعدتين
للضربات الرد الروسي كان متوقعا جدا وهذا
ما رايناها بالامس عندما
توجيه اكثر من 70 صاروخ مجنح على مختلف
الاهداف العسكريه والاقتصاديه في اوكرانيا
بصرف النظر عن تصريحات وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه بان تم اسقاط 99%
هناك سيت سرقه تصريحاته اخرى ايضا
للزلنسكي يؤكد فيها على ضروره استعاده
القرم رغم جميع المحاولات حتى من قبل
الولايات المتحده يعني تدعو اوكرانيا بان
تكون اكثر واقعيه ولكن زنس كي يؤكد على
ضروره هذا الامر على الارض ما مدى واقعيه
هذا الطموح وهل من اليوتيوب هول هي التي
تحسم الامر
الى
انسحاب جميع القوات الروسيه من كل الاراضي
التي تم الاستدعاء عليها وعوده الحدود الى
الموقع كما هو كان في 1991 همم
يعني صاحب همم
انسحاب الروسي من شبه جزيره الكرامه هذا
شيء خيالي ولم يتحدث ابدا وهذا دليل
ابدا ابدا اطلاقا لا يمكن
حتى التوقع
لتطور الاحداث بهذا الاتجاه هذا الشيء من
المستحيل من المستعد
المحلل العسكري الروسي من
موسكو
[موسيقى]
بنسبه تضخمنا ووصلت الى 84% في المئه
وعمله
يبحثوا حزب العداله والتنميه على اوراق
الانتخابيه تضمن له البقاء في السلطه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه على
الابواب يونيو
جمله اصطبق بها الرئيس التركي اردوغان
اطلاق العمليات العسكريه في سوريا والعراق
بالامس القريب واليوم استخدمها لتحديد
اجاره اخرى اليونان وفي اشاره ايضا على ما
يبدو لتوقيت الهجوم التركيه على قبرص قبل
38 عاما الخامسه والنصف فجرا القوميه
وخطاباتها الورقه او السلاح الاقوى في
معركه اردوغان الانتخابيه اليوم خاصه اذا
وجهت ضد خصمين تاريخيين الاكراد
اليونانيين والتوقيت مثلي توترات حدوديه
وحشود عسكريه
اللاجئون الورقه المفضله يتبادلها كل من
الحزب الحاكم والاحزاب المعارضه 200 الف
ناخبنائيا حذرون من سوريا ليبيا والعراق
وافغانستان وستذهب كل اصواتهم للحزب
الحاكم بحسب الشعب الجمهوريه اكبر احزاب
المعارضه الحزب ذاته تعهد بوضع خطه تضمن
وعوده لاجئين السوريين الطوعيه الى سوريا
خلال عامين عبر الحوار مع نظام الاسد حمار
يبدو ان اردوغان الصداقه المعارضه اليها
بعد لقاءات المتعدده جمعت مسؤوليه اجهزه
الاستخبارات في البلدين برعايه الروسيه
تمهيدا للقاء الرئاسي مع الاسد ابو
عيدانتخابات 2020 لا اعدا دائما في
السياسه وهذا كلام اردوغان 20%
نسبه واصوات اكراد تركيا يمكنها ترجيح فوز
مرشح التحالف الحاكم او تحالف احزاب
المعارضه كما فعلت في 2019 نصفها يذهب الى
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه الكرديه بينما كان
العداله والتنميه يحصل على نحو سبعه في
المئه من الاصوات الكرديه
يبدو الوضع اليوم مختلفا خسر الحزب الحاكم
دعم الاكراد المتديننين بسبب السياسات
القوميه التي ازدادت التطرفا ضد الاكراد
والاقتصاد كلمه السر التي اوصلت العداله
والتنميه للسلطه في نوفمبر 2002 على اثري
ازمه اقتصاديه حاده التخلص منها ابقى
الحزب في السلطه ل 20 عاما واليوم تحولت
نعمه الاقتصاد في تركيا الى
تهدد عرشه في السلطه بعد ما اوصلته اليه
في 2010
هذا اردوغان بزياده الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي الى تريليونين دولار الوصول
لقائمه ال 10 الكبار اقتصاديا بحلول 2023
اي بعد ايام لكن المؤشرات على الاخفاق
بدات منذ 10 سنوات بين عامين 2013
و20121 انخفض الناتج المحلي الاجمالي من
957 مليار دولار الى
815 مليارا وتراجعت تركيا في قائمه
الاقتصادات العالميه الاكبر من المركز
السادس عشر الى التاسعه عشر
حاول اردوغان حلاق بعضهم معدلات الاقتصاد
بتشجيع الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وتقديم
الجنسيه التركيه للمستثمرين في العقارات
في مبلغ لا يقل عن 40000 دولار سلاح ذو
حدين ساهم في تدفق العملات الاجنبيه لكنه
اشعل اسعار السلع الاساسيه بالنسبه للعديد
من الاتراك ومن بينها الخبز لكنها فئه من
الاتراك حصنها اردوغان انتخابيا ضد
تداعيات الازمه الاقتصاديه دائره
المستفيدين من الدعم المالي الحكوميه
عندما وصل الحزب الى السلطه عام 2002 كان
عدد المتلقين للمعونات الحكوميه حوالي
0.38% من الشعب التركي اليوم تخطط النسبه
حاجز الواحد فاصله 37% كما يدين مئات
والالاف من موظفي الدوله التركيه للولاء
الى اردوغان واحد الذين حارس على تعييني
وترقيه انصار الحزب يغشاها هؤلاء سيناريو
ياتي بحكومه جديده تغير الكادر الحكومي
وتاتي باتباعها
الورقه التاليه لاردوغان والتي اشرنا
اليها قبل قليل هي اليونان الخلافات بين
البلدين حول جزر بحر ايجاد فصاعدت عام
2000 تحديدا مع اكتشاف احتياطات كبيره من
النفط والغاز الشرقي المتوسط اضافه الى
ثرواتها الطبيعيه بتمون اهميه الجزر في
موقعها كان نقطه اتصال مباشر مع عدد من
البحار المفتوحه والسيطراتها على عدد من
المضائق والخللجان التي تجعلها تتحكم في
الوضع الاجمالي للملاحه الحره في المنطقه
الجره الثانيه سباق تطوير الثرسان البحريه
والبدايه بتركيا العام الجاري دخلت غواصه
باريس تركيا الخدمه والاولى ضمن ست غواصات
فئه فئه وهي نسخه من الغواصات الالمانيه
الشهيره 24 لا تصدر الغواصه صوتيه
يضاف الى ظروف الجغرافيا المحيطه بتركيا
من بحار شبه مغلقه ومياه ضاحيه قدرتها على
التخفي فائقه
عاملات الطائرات بمثابه مطارات عائمه
يمكنها الرسول لفترات طويله في اماكن لا
يمكن لطائرات القوات البريه الوصول اليها
وهنا حاملات تي جي جي انادول وهي نسخه
معدله من السفينه اخوان كارلوس الاسبانيه
كان يفترض بناؤها لمقاتلات اف 35 بيئه
التي لم تستلمها انقره فقررت تعديل خطه
التصميم لتتكون حمولتها من المروحيات
والمسيرات اليونان من جانبها تعملوا على
رفع مستوى الردع البحري ده تعاقد مع باريس
على شراء فرقه اف دي اي مجهزازه برضارات
حديثه توفر توفره قدرات عاليه المستوى في
مجالات الحرب الالكترونيه المضاده
للطائرات والغوا ويطيح التسليح الجيد
للفرقاطه تنفيذا مهام مرافقه مضاده
للغواصات اليونانيه مارك بي او مارك 5
زورق دوريه خاصه امريكا الصنع
استخداماته متعدده وابرزها تنفيذ عمليات
الاعتراض البحري اليونان قويه ايضا
مفتوح للزوار ومجانا الساعه 2:00 في زياره
لمقر شركه ابل في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
من مجال الابتكارات اقتحمت السياسه بعصفه
لم تهدا منذ ان تسيد الملياردير المثير
للجدل تويتر
وفي بعض القرارات ثائر شخص قبل ايام ماسك
حسابا تتبع طائرته الخاصه من خلال تويتر
اخذت منحا جديد
وتهديدات وصلت احتمال فرض عقوبات هذا موقف
الاتحاد الاوروبي فهل يتوقف ماسك غرد
مجددا وبغموض قريبا ايها الساده والسيدات
رصاصه الرحمه وعلى من سيطلقها ماسك
يفتحوا ماسك صندوق تويتر الاسود
وبذلك يثير عاصفه من
جهه من جهه اخرى فما الذي يريده ماسك من
تسريدي ملفات تويتر مسلسل وثائقه تويتر
الداخليه طالت قضايا مختلفه تظهر كيفيه
التعامل التعامل المنصه في الاداره
السابقه معها ويبدو ان مصر جزء
تلك القضيه ولا على القضيه التقرير صحيفه
نيويورك بوست عن نجل الرئيس الامريكي
على قضيه الرقابه هنا قرر تويتر
مع اقتراب موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه فالتقرير تناول بيانات من
كمبيوتر فتحت الباب على ما قال انه قيل
انه استغلال النفوذ السياسي يتوالت حلقات
التسريب
ظل او التقليد السري لوصول الاشخاص الى
محتوى معين لمستخدم الماء المسؤولون في
تويتر يسمونها فلتره الرؤيه فيما يراها
اخرون قمعا
كشفوا كشف المستور لم يقف عند هذا الحذف
المنصه لديها قوائم سوداء سريه تظهر ايضا
تظهر ايضا ان الاداره السابقه لتويتر كانت
متحيزه لاطراف في مقيدت اخرى لكن هل انتهى
الامر عند هذا الحد بالتاكيد لاربما لن
ينتهي قريبا فماسك الذي تعهد باستعادته
ثقه الجمهور تويتر في الكشف عن المزيد من
الملفات الحساسه ومفاجاه اخرى على مستوى
اعلى
الجزء الرابع من الملفات كشف عما يوصف
بتعاون بين مسؤوليه تويتر والديمقراطيين
والوكالات الفيدراليه لعزل الرئيس السابق
هل هذا يعني تم علاقات وثيقه لمسؤوليته مع
الكالات الفدراليه هذا ما تقوله الوسائط
بل وتشير الى اجتماعات اسبوعيا مع مكسبي
التحقيقات الفيدرالي ووزاره الامن الداخلي
والاستخبارات الوطنيه تكشفوا تلك الملفات
ايضا ما وصف بخفايا الاستراتيجيات
المتغيره في الشركه ومهد في ازاله حساب
ترامب وهنا مفاجاه من العيار الثقيل
الضغوط لالغاء حساب ترامب لم تكن من داخل
الشركه فحسب وانما من خارجها ميشيل اوباما
نعم زوجته الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق باراك
اوباما جاء حاضر وترامب من تويتر بعد يوم
من طلباتها بازالته نهائيا لكن اين الرئيس
التنفيذي السابق لشركه تويتر من كل هذه
التسريبات
ظهر واعترف بالاخطاء في دارته
لقد حان الوقت الان لشركات وديع السيليكون
التوقف عن تمكين هذا السلوك الوحشي وحضري
هذا الرجل بشكل دائم هذا ما قلته ميشال
اوباما في رساله واجهتها الى مسؤوليه
تويتر وكشفت النقابه عنها الجزء الرابع من
التسريبات التي نشرها ملكه تويتر
في السابع من يناير عام 2021 وادت لحظ
حساب الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
اظهرت الملفات وايضا ان تويتر حافظ على
سياسه تسمى استثناءات من اجل المصلحه
العامه حين لم يتم حظر المسؤولين
المنتخبين حتى لو بدا انها تنتهي سياسات
اخرى في حين تم رفعوا تعليقه ترامب المؤقت
لانه تم تجاهل هذه السياسه على وجه
التحديد
لن نتحدث
الانفايدر الحصول على المزيد من الايرادات
وتحديدا من
مستخدموها يصنعون احد عشر دولارا بدلا من
ثمانيه للاشتراك في تويتر بلو خطه تشمل
ايضا اجباره المستخدمين على الاشتراك في
الاعلانات وتتبع المنصه لهواتهم وبيع
ارقام الهواتف في زياده الاراده وهذا
ينتحك العديد من ارشادات ابل ستور
وبالتالي الشركه لن تكون سعيدا يبقى سؤال
لماذا يصير وماسك على اشعلي حرب حرب
السر ال30 في المئه ثلث ارادات الشركات من
كل تنزيل وهو ما يجعل ماسك يرى بان قفل
الشركات ولذلك اعلانه عزمه على تصنيعه
هاتف النقاله لم يكن من باب المنافسه لكنه
ماسك ربما انا قفل هي اكبر شركه في العالم
وانها اساسا تحتفظ باموال ورسوم التنزيل
لاي تطبيق ولا تفرج عنها لاصحابه قبل
اقتطاع حصتها الثلاثين في المائه بنظري
ماسك ايضا هي اعلى عشر مرات مما ينبغي
ومسك مع تويتر في مازق هناك ديون صفقه
الاستحواذ 13 مليار دولار وفوائدها مليار
ومئتين مليون دولار سنويا اكتشف ماسك
الخطا عالميا ولديه خطا للتخلص من المنصه
بعد ثلاث سنوات لكن قبل التخلص يجب اولا
استرجاع على 44 مليارا التي اشترى بها
منصه ومن هنا جاءت رسوبه
[موسيقى]
سياره
المحتمله وسناخذكم الى ما كان يوما حلما
وتحول الى حقيقه
لدينا الفرصه لبناء افضل مبنى اداريا في
العالم كلماته ستيف جوبز مؤثر